hello and welcome to this video the
national master fly away with that lewis
powder superior ok never heard him of
him so sking french defence and i really
don't see this all that often lots of
files and see fires yeah this is a good
line for black believed to be probably
the best response to the turusch
nowadays yeah should seven it's not very
common i think i know a six and Bishop
to Bishop d7 in this position I wonder
if not be five is a reason for those
news yeah I don't know I'm try to play
solid movie I don't know theoretical
details him so what is he going to do
Bishop c6 I can always take so try to
play a Bishop f4 year possible Knight to
f5 it also be an idea maybe yeah this is
probably something I'm I'm threatening a
little bit yep right at five
okay yes some prevented it it may be
Bishop g5 next step to her resume he has
Bishop b5 though oh but in general this
should be M wow wow so he's basically
saying that night f5 he's got efore
night age six chick teenage a two yeah
probably doesn't seem like I have
something great if I have to move the
night back and this was definitely
helpful for black hmm but what happens
if i play night at five if all night h6
check King H a drupe takes e4 90's night
of seven ook cheeks and peace down so
that's not good hmm yeah but my position
is terrible if I have to move the night
back I always relied on 95 is there
anything else I can do Bishop g5
probably not that's really terrible
I don't even have a good square like a
92 or something is pretty bad and I just
didn't consider this me five is
strategically speaking a terrible move
let's say but it works I mean it's good
move we I never considered it because of
usually night f5 would just be terrible
but here it was strong because of you
for so I did not have a concrete enough
approach to this position I was just
playing on general grounds even though
I'm not sure if I really have a problem
here don't don't get Ricky five that's
what's this we should air force my idea
here wasn't clear to me before is good
for him in the first place
yeah okay we should be three Ruby one
that's still quite solid hear her white
or isn't it I don't like my time
situation but the position I don't think
it's that bad the rock is funky here
does he want to play rook h5 and then
try to sacrifice e I don't think that
should work ok
Bishop to g4 93 this kind of setup would
be good and I also need route 81 I need
to centralize him yeah that isn't all
that bad this pollution yeah this is a
little bit of an annoyance ready i'm
expected this move for a while but he
never played it when i have to place
before I cannot allow Bishop to d3 and
then the Queen also didn't have any good
square so someone from catching up here
timewise yeah but Bishop takes a tree
and threatening to take some gets traded
and now night here rook age five is 95
so yeah a 95 yes is actually interesting
III at the end is quite irritating so
I'm probably just doubling the night
only 3 is pretty good it has some good
influence on the center night h 52 f 4
said something okay
King to age seven I don't know why went
there I had f4 but the dead was I was
unclear to me this ever does anything
positive root g six maybe a group t6
could be interesting just let's push it
back
I queena for he's got quinta a form
that's a bit annoying really should I
should have prevented this now g3 can
actually take on edge form time morning
very stupid my position was quite ok
actually and then i blundered this maybe
even night you for him
I will squid okay again that's a bit of
a shame that I got myself into into this
trouble again check nice quite slow here
check check check game draw yeah
whatever Jim yeah just not a
particularly good game by the way if you
want to complain about this at the end
and I simply give up now one on this
thing if I can play on time like in this
case I will do that and this will stop
complaining about people doing the same
I just I just don't want to give away
all those points by being mr. nice guy
the least of it just takes like 10
seconds to do I don't mind playing a
couple of senseless moves and get the
point or here have a point yeah so that
was kind of funny here all of a sudden
the c5 move Jim I never considered it
because this is usually it's just very
good yeah this is a very weak square I'm
threatening all kinds of things goody
for is winning him winning for him so if
I was an interesting good move the
engine isn't all that impressed just the
things I'm still okay after night to see
to gym now yep yeah I'm just a little
bit worse but I wasn't sure if before
was that great actually because I didn't
feel like this is so bad for me I mean
here my pieces have quite decent squares
the bishops are okay and I actually felt
before i blundered that I rather be
white in this production like here I
think this is a bit more comfortable for
white his bishop is pretty awful day on
c6 and I have chances owner on the
defiant on the queenside but I screw
this up really look to you 6 p-3 year
here for was good yeah hmm yeah he
doesn't have good squares for the rook i
played this that was probably not a
great idea at least this was realized
this was better this was bad like g3
yeah it just wasn't a good idea probably
in the first place to play this the
engine wants to play our guy didn't
switch it on I'm sorry the engine wants
to play a 4 here which is strong using
the same yeah this is quite quite
clearly a bit better for white this
isn't not a great route down yeah this
was bad yeah i'm just getting into
trouble each voice was gone ok let's you
for was winning
how exactly yeah just cannot defend that
him something like that yeah ac3 also
jim and 94 ganda was what's killing me
home i am at least somehow continuing to
play 95 that's cold blooded know now
that that's not a move i can play but it
looks truth tefu well if I was hanging
this is the poignant mmm yeah thanks
that wasn't on my radar and he is again
clearly better I could have taken you
for here okay didn't see it and he I was
came on some more f four winds up spell
it by that he had shattered in no time
on the clock cha yeah okay now we have
some nitrous clicking as mentioned i
want to give the way draws anymore if i
can get time points here and in exchange
i won't complain about others doing the
same I just um I just feel them it's
kind of yeah we had to always give away
the points and never get anything in
return in similar situations okay guys
not a good game but yeah thanks for
watching